this is a real thoughts on children
creatures me immortal yeah yeah the
angle we have here is a little different
because I want the tripod at the office
okay I didn't know we were gonna do this
today I was gonna try and do it tomorrow
but time constrictions and stuff so
we're gonna look like gods while we talk
to you much like form for Isaac thought
he was a god and Oh Isaac hello yeah and
if you want to please us as gods is he
our reason we got this angle Oh
we are selling new prints by the way
here's the picture of one right here uh
so see anything no you don't goes where
she doing this oh you're doing it in
post yes in fact this picture probably
Beth and Tim have inside that picture
yet but they're going to today so yeah
if you don't see it on there they will
also sign that picture and we have a
bunch of other ones as well so
definitely go check that out you can see
maybe awesome store com so now that we
got that plug out of the way let's talk
about uh yet another story from our
darling Stephen King um sister
I feel bad because I always feel bad
talking about him but he just gives so
much entertaining material to talk I
think well I think part of it is a lot
of people just like why do you hate
Stephen King we really don't know maybe
honey the funny thing is I on a
technical level I think he's one of the
best popular writers out there like his
stories are always gorgeously written
they're like page turners he haven't
really boys he wrote this book and it's
all good advice about how to write well
like from a technical level my thing is
I just don't like it stories that's what
the problem is there's so many writers
who are just like they could tell a good
thing they basically have a good story
in their head but when you read it it's
like garbage like it's just poorly
written in this an epic just like all
the story was good but I could barely
get through it he's the opposite to me
it's like it's like I love like flipping
pages through his books but by the end
of it I'm like really that's what
happened like that way okay well and
this I haven't read the short story that
a preacher it's a short story that most
based on um he a lot of the lesser ones
are and you can tell because the film's
then feel padded like wow this would
have been a great 20 minute short movie
yeah um well in this one
the idea of scary children is really
nothing new women the firt out there
sorry yeah out of you here there's just
like this burger I don't know just
everyone's well we'll just hear this
bird we try to look outside see if
anything's around but no it's Isaac yeah
I go yeah that was like something out of
a Stephen King yeah everyone's why I
don't know if you can hear it but yeah
you just yes so just ignore that uh
animal cruelty right in front of you
know we tried to find where this bird is
and we can so everyone's while we just
hear that um okay yeah very very strange
so that's gonna get you a haunting
atmosphere ah to this V login so no I
don't think Stephen King is a bad writer
no he's an awesome person everybody see
material yeah he seems so yeah I know I
love like like some of the tweets itself
he puts out and like whenever I see him
in interviews he's great it is this
stories just don't do much for me and
part of it is I'm not really scared by
monsters hmm
so much so and in some cases it's like
like The Shining I think is an OK story
but when push came to shove I like the
Kubrick film better because the book and
the miniseries is about Redemption
that's scary like give me the Kubrick
film where it's like no he's just
fucking nice metal like what no no happy
bittersweet ending to that one one again
the the idea of scary kids has been done
for a while with like the bad seed
Village of the Damned stuff like that
uh you know but it was a not a bad idea
to have an update of it you know and
honestly this idea of these children
that formed their own religion and a
cult and you know even the title as
strange as it sounds children of the
corn it sounds so silly but also like it
kind of be creepy to its or walks that
line funny thing is you when I was a kid
the movie posters like scared me digit
like the whole concept of children of
the corn just kind of scared me because
I knew I would probably be one of the
first children oft when the call took
over I just I always knew that I had no
ability to survive any situation ever
anything bad happens I would be the
first one to die so I just the whole
concept like oh yeah my peers take over
and they're running a cult I'd be the
first to go because I'd be like
guys are acting like assholes we make
kill yep Oliva so um but this movie as
we can't explained in the review is
pretty dull
obviously sorry so my children of the
snore is what I call it obviously very
boring movie surviving on the shock
value cuz again I think it's like it
like the idea of a killer clown is like
who just ideas so cranky but I think
people are just intimidated by the idea
problem is this killed in the 80s when
this seems shocking nowadays I think a
lot of people look at children in the
corner just like like particularly
people younger than us and they're like
what was the big deal yeah like okay so
children kill some people it's not that
like cuz we got we're seeing all the
time in America just got all the time in
America be like we've got litter we got
like fucking Game of Thrones we got the
Hunger Games Hunger Games which was that
stupid did not paranormal activity right
now not the purge there's some other one
where it's like a bunch of kids are
killing like their parents and their
brothers and sisters or something
because some boogeyman is telling them
to I don't know I don't know I miss that
one I can't remember the name of it but
there's a ton of them now it's
everywhere now so this really like
watching it from like today it it's just
a whole bunch of nothing the things that
stand out to it uh to me about it which
is why I said I think we should do this
review because we both have it being
kind of boring vowels like like well
yeah Isaac and really all the kids the
kids are all pretty good the main kids
are a little boy but the coast even good
project the kids are all amazing in the
adult actors so yeah that's after the
shining that was pretty decent all
around but it but yeah this thing kind
of like Stephen King's it where I'm like
man but I'm so into the kid story uh
movies like is stand by me
like that's another where the kid actors
are great that it that seems to be a
common theme I don't know if it right
kids very well I feel remember summer
shoes maybe yeah I think it's because he
remembers what it's like to be a kid
better so if you write that really well
and then all you have to do is translate
it to screen that might be easier like a
kid maybe pick up
I don't know but yeah so the kids roll
made that fucking ginger kid ha ha hi
why I saw that I was young that kid just
gave me the creeps like oh my god yeah
so the kids are all grade that um
whatever that guy was twenty year olds
or whatever that did uh yeah he wasn't
even a kid that that guy man I wish I
could remember his name I feel bad now
but I don't know we were doing this
still amazing yeah it's one of these
that's one of my favorite performances
in any Stephen King film he's just so
much he's like it you know is he's like
a little uh Joffrey from game of pure
yeah I always feel like Joffrey was
tapping in that sort of just I am snug
and I am God and you will do my bidding
or I will kill you there is a sense that
maybe that's why it was a hit and people
still can't remember is that all the
kids when you see them talking
everything they look like they really
legitimately believe what they're saying
and the relief or stuff like that well
they drank the kool-aid yeah I will say
actually as a when I was a kid cuz I saw
it was pretty young it didn't scare me
but it was kind of the first
introduction you know to a religion that
was so obviously false but they were
trying to convince themselves it was
razn is kind of real too there is this
monster and did it okay that's enough of
a break before you I'm gonna be finished
but it was the first movie that as a
youngin actually did sort of say to me
hey any religion that is not you know
that includes hurting people and that
were better than you and we have to
destroy you know anything on violence
and anger and adrien jealousy is false
and I just remember that word just Falls
and then that just felt right and you
know now this movie is made for adults
it's like well you would think most
adults can catch on to that but we're
seeing that necessarily but as a little
kid I just remember that really really
stuck with me and so it is something I
really did take from this movie even
though it's clearly not intended for
kids but I think like it a lot of kids
saw it um so I did kind of like what
okay like growing up in the 80s you were
always trying to get into like r-rated
films or you were always trying to find
the friend whose parents would rent the
our rated films or does that still
happen like I feel like now is our it on
the internet like that now you grab them
so yeah um but yeah that was such a huge
thing so I think a lot of us like saw it
anyway yeah um well they would still
show it on TV so if cuz there's nothing
really there's not that much swearing
there's not that much gore that I
remember uh you know thank you by
today's standards it's pretty timid up
yea orsa network television yeah
honestly on and for TV it's like if
there are some swearing you just bleep
about and boom it's like peaches movie
that's why the movie resonated with me
because up until the stupid ending which
is stupid
I say it's stupid cuz it's stupid it's
like that damn spider in it yeah up
until then like those sort of stories
resonated with me more because they were
real I'm like yeah you know the next
thing you go to school and you're like
looking around in time to figure out
okay which would be the killer in this
group
I know I was I was just like you you you
little rat bastard you'd kill me
like but there was a certain reality to
stories that were more they were about
humans succumbing to their darker side
than the Senedd monsters monsters never
scared me ghosts kind of scared me for
some reason but monsters they never did
I had a fear of I had a fear of some
monsters in the sense of they were more
animal-like particularly depending on
how realistic it was at like alien
aliens yeah alien and aliens but that
was cuz it was like it was like an
animal like after you and the Terminator
scared me because that was just like
some robot that you know and you
couldn't reason with your life into you
and that was pretty scary on those kind
of things but for the most part most
movie monsters that you would see like
in Steven they're do it the killer knows
behind the rows or yeah or even though
like like poltergeist that clown thing
never scared of Poppa there are scary
sounds a guy do not age well I'm sure
the remake is worth but does not age
whether like there are scenes of
poltergeist when I was a kid they scared
by how I be but it wasn't that the sea
but the corpses in the pool I didn't go
see any that was like that was pretty
creepy but the clown actually never
sewed yeah and so the first part like I
remember children of the corn will
it really scared me when I was young and
then that ending
like completely like just destroys it it
destroys that in two levels one it is so
fucking unimpressive that it's just you
all we can do is laugh at it like cuz
even I'm just gonna say that you are too
an explosion
don't it like if you're if you're some
Alinea watching this and it is like a me
a me state that doesn't know we didn't
talk about Oh stupid oh yeah we have
fucking star wars so in the 80s like
that that was shitty special-effects
back that like that was laughable um
that was like the CGI baby in Twilight
yeah I get like and people are gonna
look at it's like really they thought
those are good effects no nobody did so
they're terrible effects and - I think
it takes away from the whole kind of
like message behind it when it's like oh
alright well it's just a monster so I'm
like well then really I guess they were
kind of right you know as are like well
this monster will kill you if you don't
do its bidding them like well then they
were completely justified in running
this cult yeah it's not like oh they'll
be like a Fiat it is now sure it ties
into Dark Tower into whatever or
whatever that people drive the Stephen
King expanded you yes haha yes ke you um
but yeah that's that's what bothered me
about it cuz I'm like it's not a power
play for Isaac like that would have been
creepier to me it was just like no Isaac
just made this up cuz he's a fuck and
then he's got these other little fox who
follow him which is always what happens
in middle school okay man i'ma go to bar
but nobody that would have been creepier
instead this is like oh well a monster
told him to do and I'm like well then I
guess it's the monsters fault then I
don't really I'm not scared
anyway yeah something that monsters in
us people hit on something that I
thought as a kid I didn't want to know
the answers to think I didn't want to
know what was running the tonico I
didn't want oh if it was real or if you
kids and that odd you know in
Independence Day I didn't want to see
the aliens you know but they showed the
aliens and there's always this sense
where you know the birds we don't know
why they do that in the movie and that
is so much scarier to me so mile
friendship Alfred Hitchcock has the
things for blondes and torturing them
by that it but but I mean it's one of
those things where it's like the
scariest stuff to me are the ones where
they leave they give you just enough for
it to be scary but they don't answer why
and I think so much of the world like a
lot that fear comes from not knowing why
why terrible people do terrible things
and stuff feeling king like about
witness have been so Mohini Europe it
just you know they stop these kids they
get every no whatever the people out and
yeah you never know why that happened I
fell didn't be so terrified and I have
not read that story and so like what
happens Shaun of a corn was a short yeah
it was sort of I I feels like a
collection of lakhs guys forget which in
a lecture that's from but I want to say
it was like in the eighth grade when I
read it last I forget if he behind the
rows was in it yeah so we want to say I
want to say we don't know how much X's
can I forgive but if it if it was I want
to say it was but it sounds like a king
ending okay if it was he didn't need it
like king literally could have just
wrote this as just Isaac psychotic and
they somehow defeat him the end or that
maybe there's some crazy preacher that
put it into Isaac's end point being if
he kept it human I think it'll been Wade
yeah or you just don't know you don't
know if it was actually something or
reveals just the kids or whatever you
know or Isaac brain knows that's not
some shit weasel wandering around yeah
all right I really lose something when
you do that when you answer too much uh
I think that's really when your special
effects can pick it out I think that's
why ghosts got so popular for a while
stuff like you know the ring and
paranormal activities and six ensign
stuff cuz you just you don't know we
don't know how goes work we don't know
why they're bad we don't know what their
weakness is only I'm just gonna say this
moral of the Ring that's about where I'm
like more scarier than they were than a
the miniseries a book in a shiny because
this is a little more behind as I know
now you can't reason with this thing
it's just a fucking bitch Oh like and
that scares me
uh you're voting off this time haha look
at me take a drinking game how many
times or how let's go on um but no you
know you brought the ring um everyone to
what I get every once in a while showing
what the monster is or you think it's
gone or whatever and then suddenly it
comes back you like just take you out of
your
when I was irate payoff for the speed
out effect I am I am TV look and it was
just so unexpected that in the movie so
when it does that at the end it's like
whoa and it totally just catches you
off-guard it takes you out of your
comfort zone so I can understand do it I
can understand giving this sudden answer
to something for Canada shock and
Canada's final hit there was no fun
there wasn't a motivation fine yeah and
I think but with some stories I think
they just got so you know caught up with
a thing like this is their one chance
and a guy gives you everything
everything has to be explained what it's
like the scarier things I'm wondering
why it was always that video it was
always it just sort of led there imagine
if the ring was really about a group of
creepy kids and all of a sudden the ring
ghost pops out of nowhere uh me be like
well what the fuck is this like none of
this was building up today's felt like
whoa key behind the rows and is that
okay I guess that's build up but at the
same time I thought it was like oh it's
a metaphor for maybe some creepy dude
that told him visitors in but anything
it was gonna be some cheesy 80s music
video mods it's like a bad MTV Music
Video like from 1984 hmm I guess there's
always did more there's always a very
clan again I don't know how much of this
is tied in a king with the movie but
there's always a very obvious anti
religious thing in his movies we know
nobody I wasn't given the time that they
were written I mean it is something
where it's like I definitely see why and
you definitely know he prized a pass
with it and stuff but there is a sense
that every single movie has some
religious figure who's an asshole I mean
just always and with this one again I
think I give it a little bit credit at
the very end he comes around and he's
not saying all religion is shit it's all
false even though they both very much
believe that he's saying that anyone
that has hatred and anger at the focus
is false and I do respect I have no
problem with Stephen King having issues
with organized religion um cuz yeah so
yeah x7r oh yeah it's but you know I got
the I'm sorry but yeah that's my place
it gets everyone is it's become a trope
yeah and I don't like it as a trope and
by children of the carnie was really
starting to become like okay here we go
again by the mist the mist is one more I
just I wanted to strangle the movie
where I'm just like I will say this
about the mists
it really captured the tedium of being
trapped in a place with a bunch of
assholes you really can't stand cuz I
was just like I hate this grocery store
I hate these assholes I hate that
fucking crazy lady and when you know it
she's a religious nutjob and she's free
sure about the end of the world and I'm
like justjust I'm stabbing myself with
like a drinking straw like just kill me
how that sounds go dude
I love it sup ok so I just get sick of
it I'm like I get it you don't like
organized religion or crazy right-wing
religious nut jobs i more sympathetic is
obviously either but like it's just
enough already it's a either religious
nut job monsters or boys that's kind of
it Freeman a bag inmate at least by the
movies uh so I like a mist I got a lot
of Steven I got Stephen King bingo on
now and it was like whatever I like told
well my favorite book if he is is misery
and that's because you know the villain
in that you can human he yeah one human
a different set up it's an obsessed fan
you know I barely know guys we like
nobody before for that even before that
you was kept sit up there was no
supernatural thing there was nothing
that was trying again there was no super
big backstory or anything is just here
and it's gawking today it just keeps you
in that room got some of the tropes but
you know uh the stuck in the middle of
the elements you can't go anywhere
claustrophobic the crazy lady but so
it's got some of the trunks but the way
he uses them yeah well you better yeah
and I thought that was just enough of a
really good job and nice that's why the
examines like is there any Stephen King
stories I'm like I like misery I like
Dolores Claiborne I like a lot of his
Shapiro's days um you know I liked
Shawshank
you know a lot of the ones like that
translated that's about the best
adaptation you could get the Stephen
King film the Shawshank yeah I can't
think of one that's really better um I
never did see Cujo I hear that one's
pretty good
you don't you haven't seen Cujo single
object I won't say something about the
ones where it's one person isolated I
mean nowadays that getting very hard to
do well and get interesting because
we've just seen it so much and it
do it well now it's been done a million
times so he had to really try hard to
make it done well and I think he does
them very well they translate well into
movies um so yeah when he does that
stuff particularly I think they're like
you know it's good because it's good
writing with a good story yeah and a
good idea too of the court I remember
liking the story when I read it of
course I was like barely in my teen
years but I just felt like watching the
movie again having not seen it in
forever I'm like it is so padded and so
don't like you could get through like
this movie in 45 minutes if you just
took out all the padding and this and
that and it and just like Linda
Hamilton's performance is great but her
character is mostly useless and then hit
her boyfriend or fianc or whatever is I
know he just came off as a dick to me in
the hallway was is always like there
there dear
there there okay uh you know what I'll
just just listen to me I'm the dude here
like there was just something there some
about him yeah it's more of it than I
did I didn't write him but he has
rubbing me the wrong way the like from
the very beginning he just had that
maybe some of us cuz like his character
was a doctor and he just had that
holier-than-thou like listen I'm the
smart one here like dr. graduate he just
became a doctor yeah yeah I don't know
there's just something douchey about him
that was like this guy's bugging me and
so about the ending to reminds me of
like commando where it's like they have
the two kids it's like oh what do we do
these two munchkins I just immediately
thing like commando the musical QC deuce
woman and she's going to be your new
model I thought oh I just get the kids
now done I just started humming the
Jurassic Park theme because I was like
all I need to do is even the helicopter
it's the same ending well I guess these
two kids are mine yeah that's kind of at
that time where it's always like the kid
doesn't have like two parents or
whatever it's like you just can't see
the serenity just
yet part of the plot I forget was that
part of the discussions they were having
enjoying the quorum where they were
gonna have kids no it's like he didn't
want to get married that was he didn't
want to give it but that I feel like
myself I gotta have like a family this
is something for like 10 years or it's
like will they want to get married will
they want to conceive like cuz that was
the whole centerpiece of Jurassic Park
it's like will dr. grant want to spread
his seed yeah there's something about
the family connection that like in the
80's and 90's just like you know and the
family is important uh but I think
especially the past like 20 years with
just how much divorce there is an
families tree maybe it's the whole main
thing it's like now where's the new
family what does family me which I think
it's maybe maybe for all its grit in the
eighties there's some weird undercurrent
of family values like no you must
procreate you must have a nuclear family
yes um which is very interesting we
think about cuz the eighties you do
think about being like so violent and
extreme and gritty but yeah there is
always a morals between well we know art
and coke damn it
yeah it's like but we have to have kaya
this one moral this one family I don't
even think it was like hey you have to
have this or we're gonna beat the shit
out of you or anything like that it was
well it there's only new kind I just
want you to be a new I feel like that
was one of the kind of cheap tropes to
you know your hook in a story it was
like oh man do we really want kids I
want kids and then by the end of it it's
like well I guess we say five a lot of
kids yeah yeah I I don't know I just
feel like for some reason that was some
common well don't you remember any years
there's where the select registrar was
one of the last ones
yeah that's our Park episode where they
said or I showed you the corn and when
it's all done he's like you know I think
that this couple start whether or not
they want to have kids and you know say
so honey maybe we can give this kids
thing a try after all she's like are you
fucking nuts
hello so far oh that was a great episode
too but uh yeah so I mean I I might be
pretty dull pretty so nothing impressive
but the the kids are great the kids
waste too much fun and the adult
basically gets kids are great waste of a
Linda Hamilton role and
I don't even remember the other guy but
uh the the kids were great I clean with
the pant legged I'm trying to think
there was like one scene that was really
bugging me where I'm like okay this is
just how not to do suspense right oh
it's when she's drawing like what's
gonna happen to like Linda Hamilton or
whatever but you see the picture first
and then they start busting through the
door and abduct Lema hit Linda Hamilton
lzr way around place on after I can't
was it after something happened where
I'm just like this is not a good reveal
because we just saw it happen and then
you revealed I guess either way you
would do oh maybe it was the other way
around
oh it was the other way around cuz yeah
then after they take her how do you see
the picture I'm like company if you see
a picture first yes okay that's it
because they do it like it's some like
who's that that's you like wouldn't it
be so cool well that'd be so creepy yes
I see her like that was the probably
right across or something there right no
that's right I was thinking I was right
of the right way to go yeah yeah but
they did the wrong way to do which
afterwards they have the reveal of the
picture like Tom Tom Tom and I'm like
but this isn't a shop we just saw this
happen yeah we said like this isn't why
is this shocking why are you even
playing sting because ideas great idea
with her doing these drawings that I
think they littered it later died with
it they did now it like the others and
insidious and stuff like that they did
much more on exit it's another Stephen
King bingo
you know I've got a child with psychic
abilities like yeah um but yeah and
you're right it's like how cool would
have been you know what this would be a
fun remake if somebody just like remake
install the mistakes yeah cuz this could
actually be a very effective scary farm
to be fair they didn't get a mystery and
they did sort of do a lot boy having the
the psychic the girl you know no I'm
saying to be fair to stinking the boy
having the psychic abilities and
something like The Shining really worked
but here it's just like she's psychic
because but it doesn't really affect the
plot all that much ah it's just almost
just like that I need something creepy
she's like yeah the film never takes
advantage of it yeah it again just
padding yeah so uh that's about it you
know we're gonna try and get back to
doing more of these we took currents erm
a break for a while but I did
yeah yeah Oh God disbeliever I think you
know I think he still looks like that
too in hands later I mean he looks older
but I mean I think he still is like a
similar voice and everything so I think
for years he played like you know young
boy roles and stuff or a person that has
had somebody if they don't then somebody
would I ever see him at a convention
we're doing I told me what it's like the
second I'm like you saved children of
the glad I made that move she really did
um a lot more of him an you can never
get out of Isaac so um yeah that's about
it and we will see you next time later